Prof: To me,
the most evocative moment in
the Quixote,
as we reach the beautiful city
of Barcelona,
is the appearance of the sea.
The sea suggests the infinite,
as we approach the end,
and also death:
"Death's dateless
night," to quote
Shakespeare.
Castile is landlocked,
and so Spain is defining its
limits, as the novel reaches its
end and defines its own limits.
Don Quixote and Sancho,
most probably,
have never seen the sea,
but Cervantes certainly had,
as we know, and he boasts of it
in these last chapters of the
Quixote.
There is all these details
about life in the ships,
and of the galley slaves,
and all of that,
in which he uses very detailed
maritime terminology.
But Sancho and Don Quixote are
unlikely to have ever seen the
sea.
We are not told if they had,
but one, I think,
should assume so.
The novel, which,
as a genre began with the
Quixote, will be an urban
genre, meaning that it will deal
mostly with cities;
the settings will nearly always
be cities.
Yet, Barcelona is the only city
that appears in the
Quixote, though Part II
began with a visit to El Toboso,
a village.
Is Don Quixote doing like
Aeneas, who went from Troy to
Rome,
obviously, not,
as I said earlier,
such heroic acts are no longer
available to Don Quixote,
heroic and historically
defining acts are not available
to Don Quixote.
Besides, El Toboso is a mere
village in Spain,
and it endured no war,
like Troy, and Barcelona is not
the culmination of a journey,
and the harbinger of an empire,
like the Roman,
which the Aeneid
announces and celebrates.
It is significant that,
in contrast,
to a history,
I'll repeat this,
a history of the novel which is
mainly urban,
this is the only urban setting
in Don Quixote,
but it is urban with a
vengeance, even with its party,
its own party,
which is a party very much
something of the city,
and I'm thinking here of Le
temps retrouvé, which
is the last volume in Marcel
Proust's À
la recherche du temps
perdu,
which I hope you get to read
some day,
in which there are many parties
in that novel,
and dances, and stuff.
The first thing that Don
Quixote and Sancho endure in
Barcelona is public shame,
as when the boys goad Rocinante
into throwing Don Quixote.
The city will mean public
display, a lot of people.
It is also extremely
significant that Don Quixote and
Sancho arrive on the eve of San
Juan,
the night of the eve of San
Juan, that is to say,
they arrive during carnival
time or carnival-like time.
It is as if they had arrived at
a costume party already
costumed--at a costume ball
already costumed--because they
are literary characters already.
In fact, by this date,
1615, but by the time Cervantes
is writing this,
1613, probably,
Don Quixote and Sancho had
already appeared in a carnival.
Two men disguised as Don
Quixote and Sancho appeared in a
carnival, in a town near Lima,
Peru, in 1609.
So Don Quixote and Sancho were
already figures that--
costumed characters that people
could dress up like in the
carnival,
and here they are entering into
a carnival atmosphere.
The city of Barcelona will be a
stage for various festivals and
theater-like representations.
The city is carnival,
it is theater,
it is acting out roles,
it is the opposite of nature,
it is art.
Here, we have literary genres
compressed and staged,
like the Byzantine romance,
and the novela morisca
that I explained about in the
last lecture.
Now, the Byzantine romance
aspect or representation I
already mentioned is also called
a Greek romance;
this mini Greek romance,
which winds up Ricote's,
Ana's and Gaspar's story.
Cervantes has compressed all of
the elements of the Byzantine
romance in the story:
abductions,
sea voyages,
sea battles,
people in costume,
and it is also a reprise
of the captive's tale,
with a good ending,
however, promised to the Muslim
father.
I repeat what I said in the
last lecture that,
at this time,
Cervantes is working on his own
Byzantine romance,
The Trials of Persiles y
Sigismunda,
so it is not surprising that he
should include elements of it in
this part of the Quixote.
The new novelistic genre that
Cervantes is creating is a
compendium of narrative genres.
Remember that,
to me, the most interesting
aspect of this mini Byzantine
romance is when Gaspar Gregorio
is dressed as a woman so as to
be less attractive to his
Turkish captors.
It's kind of a baroque kind of
transvestitism;
or transvestitism sort of
turned around.
Now, that story of Gaspar
Gregorio and Ana is not
concluded, there is no closure.
The reason may be that this is
the only love story that has a
social political connection;
the whole business of the
expulsion of the moriscos
and the returning to Spain
against the law.
That is, this is not just a
story, but part of ongoing
history.
The novel, that is,
the novel Don Quixote,
like the character,
is coming closer to reality not
to the demands of fiction or of
madness.
Perhaps closure,
other than death,
is only available in those
realms.
That is, closure is only
available perhaps in fiction,
which it has its rounded
completed forms,
whereas ongoing time cannot
have closure.
Perhaps closure is possible,
then, only in fiction,
or within Don Quixote's
madness.
I continue to worry about the
ending of the novel,
with the impending ending of
the novel which must have
worried Cervantes a lot as he
moved forward.
Now, is Cervantes presenting a
falsified Spain with these
well-to-do citizens of Barcelona
and government officials who are
so lenient with the
moriscos and the
renegades,
or is it the Spain that he
would like to see?
We will never know,
but, on the whole,
there is leniency shown here,
even by the government
officials who are breaking the
law in doing so.
Now, further activities in
Barcelona take place at the
house of Antonio Moreno.
Antonio Moreno,
a character--I'm sure that you
have remarked upon--and several
social events take place at his
house.
His house is now the setting
for the action,
but we have left,
and will return,
to the duke and duchess's
house,
but now it's in Antonio
Moreno's house that these
events,
these social events take place.
Here we have depicted the
pleasures of the
bourgeoisie.
This is not quite a
bourgeoisie,
it is higher than the
it announces the emergence of
the bourgeoisie,
as a class.
Now, so the events here are not
quite as elaborate or ornate as
the ones at the duke and
duchess' palace mentioned.
But there is a dance,
in which Don Quixote displays
skills, such as dancing,
that we did not know that he
possessed, or imagined that he
possessed.
They bespeak of a past that
Cervantes chose not to fill out.
Where did Don Quixote learn to
dance?
Where did he dance?
Just as we learned in the
episode of the boat,
that he knows how to swim:
how did he ever learn how to
swim?
We are not given any details
about this past of Don Quixote;
we could imagine it.
He acts, here,
like an accomplished courtesan.
He is, as when he is at the
duke and duchess' house,
the object of entertainment,
but not of cruel pranks.
I mean, here,
these bored bourgeoisie
have parties,
and suddenly a literary
character emerges among them;
it is a godsend to them.
Imagine, you're having a party
and James Bond shows up.
Wow!
Everybody is excited;
and this is what happens at
this party.
Now, the talking head caper,
which is reminiscent of the
Master Peter episode and his
monkey,
remember the monkey who could
divine what is happening to
people,
is making--I mean,
the whole prank centers on
making literal a rhetorical
figure.
Remember, I mentioned that
Antonomasia was a rhetorical
figure, the name of the young
woman in an earlier story,
and now we have another one
here.
Here we have prosopopeia.
"Prosopopeya"
in Spanish;
"prosopopeia"
in English.
The definition of prosopopeia
is:
"a figure in rhetoric in
which things are represented as
persons or by which things
inanimate are spoken of as
animated beings,
or by which an absent person is
introduced as speaking or a
deceased person is represented
as alive and present,
a kind of personification."
That's the end of the
definition.
You have prosopopeia,
of course, when you have a
ventriloquist,
with his puppet that he makes
speak, or projects his voice and
speaks.
So that is what prosopopeia is.
So Cervantes here,
as he does in other occasions,
is hinting at the disconnection
of language from signification.
It is a staging of pure voice
without a source.
Also, he is playfully
presenting the inner world of
man as being made up of wood and
tin,
because the bust is made of
wood, made to look like stone,
or marble, or whatever,
and the whole apparatus through
which the student,
who is the assistant,
in this case,
speaks, is made of tin.
So here, other than
prosopopeia, there is a hint
that Cervantes is showing well
the inside of man,
is just like this piece of wood
with a tin tube through which
the voice emerges.
So it's, again,
one of these episodes that has
all kinds of philosophical
suggestions.
But the most suggestive episode
in Barcelona is the visit to the
printing shop.
Now, this is the acme of
self-reflectivity.
It is as if,
jokingly, Don Quixote were
visiting his true origin in the
most material sense.
Don Quixote,
a character who emerged from
books, is at the place where
books are literally made;
it is a kind of reductio ad
absurdum because literature
cannot be reduced to the
material status of paper,
ink and glue;
what you make a book with,
of course.
But Cervantes is delving into
the very basic building blocks
of his craft,
aware that these,
that is, the apparatus,
the machinery to make the book
and all of that are mere
concrete manifestations of it
that cannot be its real origin,
its real source,
but he is playing with it.
The episode,
this episode,
must be seen in relation to the
scrutiny of the books and to
Altisidora's dream or vision,
about which I will speak later
today.
They all deal with the question
of the book, the visit to the
printing shop,
I repeat, is the last frontier
of self-reflectivity.
Here is a fictional character
observing the printing of a book
about him, but the book is an
apocryphal one,
to add to the confusion.
It is Avellaneda's book.
It is a visit to the origin of
all reflections and
representations.
The sign the boys hang on Don
Quixote also reduces him to
language;
it's a label;
he is reduced to letters.
So Cervantes is taking this to
the very limits.
Now, Avellaneda's spurious
Quixote,
and you have today a handout
with the cover,
which I may have given you
before, just so that you have it
as a souvenir;
you can also look at it and
read it, as best you can.
Notice that the esses are made
like this: Tordesillas.
You can read it,
I'm sure, and also the wood cut
of the knight is also very
interesting.
Avellaneda's spurious
Quixote came to the
attention of Cervantes when he
was about...
In chapter XXXVI,
we said, or XXXVII.
So the moment that he learned
about Avellaneda's book,
and probably have read it,
he changed Don Quixote's
destination to Barcelona away
from Saragossa.
Avellaneda's book allows
Cervantes to add yet another
dimension to his play of
illusion.
Later, he will borrow a
character from the false
Quixote and make him
swear that he had never seen him
and Sancho,
seen Don Quixote and Sancho.
You will see that as we get to
the very end.
This is a parody,
that legal document that he
makes him sign.
Can you imagine?
A legal document,
a fictional character is making
another one sign saying,
of course, that he,
the one giving him the document
is the real one.
It's a parody of those legal
documents at the origin of the
constitution of the picaresque,
for instance,
but there is a great deal more,
here.
This is a meta-fictional realm
where characters from two
different novels can actually
meet and talk to each other.
The play of illusion,
the blurring of the border
between fantasy and fiction is
emphasized by these various
layers of fiction involved,
and by the brilliant move by
which Cervantes,
by not allowing Don Quixote to
go to Saragossa,
intends to correct history,
but, of course,
it's a history that is a
fiction.
There is no position from which
to stand outside of the world of
fiction in the Quixote,
because the fiction is manmade;
it is all that we can know.
In a way, and I have mentioned
this before, this anticipates
the philosophy of the great
Italian philosopher Gian
Battista Vico,
eighteenth century.
The New Science is the
name of his wonderful book.
One of Vico's main ideas was
that mankind can only understand
what mankind has made;
therefore, he begins his
history of humanity after the
flood, when it is mankind that
remakes the world,
not with Genesis.
And what I'm saying here is
that this world of fiction is
manmade,
and it is all that we can
understand,
so the modern self that emerges
from this vision is a very light
and fragile one,
like Hamlet's,
or like the one proposed by
Milan Kundera in The
Unbearable Likeness of
Being,
a novel that I suggest you read.
It is a modern self devoid of
certainties,
certainly about himself,
or herself,
because the feeling that this
mise en abîme,
this infinitely receding
sequence creates,
is that, if anything envelopes
our world,
if anything contains our world,
it may yet be another fiction.
This is the cervantean
borgesian, Borges,
I'm referring to Jorge Louis
Borges.
This is a cervantean borgesian
predicament, in which we find
ourselves and from which you
cannot escape in the
Quixote.
It is what we saw in the Las
Meninas, when we
visited Velázquez's
studio,
and by watching,
we became a part of the fiction
of the painting.
And the visit,
the visit to the printing shop
is like the visit to that studio
of Velázquez's;
this is the shop where fiction
is made.
The only way out of this
predicament is by an act of
will,
like the one that Don Quixote
performs at the end,
when he very artily spurns all
of the seductions and all of the
consolations that his comrades
offer him as he is near death.
His is an act of faith and a
voluntary one,
not an intellectual one.
Moreover, Avellaneda and his
Quixote may also
represent a misreading of
Cervantes' Quixote by the
society of his time.
Avellaneda's Quixote
presents a character that is
essentially ridiculous and
funny,
and a Sancho who is a glutton
and a drunk,
so it is the vision of the
Quixote as essentially a
funny book,
a misreading that has been
repeated in recent times by the
so called "hard
school" of critics of
Cervantes in England,
that I said that the only hard
thing about it is the hardening
of the critical arteries:
Peter Russell and company,
Anthony Close...
In a way, Cervantes preempts
all of them by doing what he
does with Avellaneda's
Quixote,
but the misreading is
interesting in itself.
If it is a misreading it is
If Avellaneda's book stands for
that misreading,
and I have quotes from two
critics,
one of whom you have heard
before, that will help clarify
that potential misreading and
also situate it historically.
One is Mariscal,
and I have looked all over to
discover this fellow's first
name and couldn't find it today.
He wrote a book on Avellaneda's
Quixote;
he is a critic who teaches at a
University in California,
and he underscores the
misreading by pointing out that
in Avellaneda's book,
Don Quixote is actually chained
and sent to jail,
not to Yale, to jail.
I cannot resist telling an
anecdote here,
that is, that my mother,
who was a professor,
and a very brilliant woman who
did very well in Greek and Latin
but had little facility for
modern languages,
including English,
and she would tell her friends
in Florida to impress them,
"My son Robert is in
Yale," and when the ladies
did not react as she hoped,
she would say,
"And he has been there a
long time!"
I had to tell her to stop
saying where I was teaching,
just to say that I was teaching
up north, somewhere.
So in any case,
in Avellaneda's book,
Don Quixote is sent to jail.
And Mariscal writes:
"Physical imprisonment in
the original text [meaning in
the Cervantes's Quixote
1605]
with the exception of the open
cage in the final chapters is
displaced by a series of images
designed to explore the
inescapable yet complex and
often tenuous inter
relationships between the self
and the social world:
ropes, strings,
nets.
In Avellaneda,
on the other hand,
the subject must be held
forcibly in place,
so that it can be the recipient
of both the law's violence and
the shame produced by the
exchanges with the community
[the subject,
here, meaning Don
Quixote]."
He goes on: "The
condemnation of Don Quixote by
the subordinate classes merely
underscores the ideological
homogeneity,
to which the Spanish elites,
with Avellaneda as spokesman,
aspired."
So you can see,
Mariscal is equating
Avellaneda's imprisoning of the
Quixote with the
mainstream ideology of the
Spanish of the times.
He goes on:
"Avellaneda imprisons his
protagonist because he is mad
[meaning the protagonist,
not Avellaneda],
yet his more pressing ambition
is to castigate the alternative
forms of subjectivity which
Cervantes had explored in his
novel.
The attempt to cultivate an
individualized existence--
the attempt to cultivate
and individualized
existence--
runs head on,
not only into the traditional
constraints of shame and
revenge,
but finally into the twin
powers of early Spanish
absolutism with Avellaneda as
their literary spokesman which
work to suppress the
attempt."
So Avellaneda's working to
suppress these forms of
subjectivity that are present in
the Quixote.
Finally:
"The refusal to align
himself with any of the
hegemonic forces at work in his
society underscores a strong
sense of wandering,
which has been noted by critics
from Lukács to Foucault
in the original Quixote.
By moving along the margins of
the dominant culture,
Cervantes' Don Quixote is not
the romantic rebel which much of
traditional criticism has wanted
him to be.
Yet, he nonetheless works to
clear a space upon which modern
forms of subjectivity would
later appear."
Unquote.
Mariscal is not aware that the
individual alternative forms of
subjectivity that he talks about
are bourgeois in origin and
destiny,
if we're going to see them from
the Marxist point of view that
he,
I presume, is looking at them
from,
moreover, he works,
I think, with a utopian vision
of the liberated self that
Cervantes would have never been
naïve enough to accept.
But what he says is very
suggestive about the source of
Avellaneda's concept of the
character that he has taken from
Cervantes.
Manuel Durán,
who you have encountered many
times, writes:
"Gilman [Stephen Gilman,
whom you have also met many
times, professor at Harvard for
many years,
and he wrote the best works on
Avellaneda]
has demonstrated the
coincidence between Avellaneda's
attitude and that of post
Council of Trent morals,
which were aesthetic and
orthodox [You know now what the
Council of Trend because you've
read it in Elliott,
no?
This is a retrenchment of
Catholic Orthodoxy in the Spain
of the time.]
Avellaneda would then be the
representative of all,
of the people's voice,
but this does not explain why
Avellaneda shows himself to be
so favorable to the
moriscos [which his
does].
His Aragenese origin [the
Aragenese were against the
expulsion]
which is probable is not
sufficient proof.
In any case,
if one accepts that
Avellaneda's book is a kind of
negative collective response by
Spain's society of the times to
the freedom and inner
independence with which
Cervantes had endowed his
characters,
we will then understand why
Cervantes did not have immediate
and direct successors,
and the reason why the modern
novel invented in Spain by
Cervantes would have to wait
until the middle of the
nineteenth century to be able to
return to its birthplace.
Official Spain [goes on
Durán]
in contrast to the nearly
underground Spain found in a
path that goes from Rojas and
the mystics to Cervantes did not
believe in individual
independence and freedoms."
What Durán means here is
that there is an official Spain,
here, orthodox,
and becoming increasingly
orthodox in the sixteenth
century,
but that there is an
underground Spain,
that goes from Rojas,
meaning Fernando de Rojas,
the author of Celestina,
through the mystics,
Saint John of the Cross,
and so forth,
who were seen with great
suspicion by the Inquisition,
to Cervantes,
and that this is a counter
official Spain.
But that Avellaneda represents
orthodox Spain,
here, above this,
which suppresses it,
and that's why he gives us that
view of the Quixote.
I hope this is clear.
Cervantes' relatively mild
response--
that's where I would like to
put all of the hard school of
critics,
there with that orthodox Spain
that represses,
you know?
Now, Cervantes's relatively
mild response to Avellaneda is
inline with his irony.
There is a great deal of humor
on what he does to Avellaneda,
and we'll see it immediately,
when we get to Altisidora's
vision.
An ironist like Cervantes can
never be so sure of himself as
to be virulent in controversy
and in debate.
How can he be so sure of
himself?
One of Cervantes' most admired
traits is this restraint and
self-mockery,
and it shows in his answer to
Avellaneda.
If you remember,
the 1605 prologue,
you remember this self mocking
Cervantes who doesn't know what
to do about writing the
prologue,
and so forth,
and so on, and all of these
authorial games by which he
distances himself from his
creation,
and all of that.
Someone with that position
could only do to Avellaneda what
he did,
according to Gilman,
he sort of threw a "net of
irony" over Avellaneda to
capture him.
He did say a few nasty things
in the prologue of the 1615
Quixote but,
of course, Avellaneda had said
terrible things about Cervantes,
mocked him even because of his
injured hand and everything.
Now, we come to what I think is
the culminating event in
Barcelona which is Don Quixote's
defeat at the hands of the
Knight of the White Moon.
The Knight of the White Moon is
the latest reincarnation of
Sansón Carrasco,
whom we learn has been pursuing
his neighbor since his failure
as the Knight of the Mirrors.
He is now in cahoots with the
duke and duchess who tell him
where Don Quixote has gone,
because Sansón looked
for him in Saragossa and did not
find him there,
of course.
The rules are carefully agreed
upon, as with the earlier
encounter, and Don Quixote is
fairly defeated within those
rules.
He speaks as if dead from
within his armor as he lay on
the ground.
The narrator says:
"Don Quixote,
bruised and stunned,
without lifting up his visor as
if he was speaking from within a
tomb,
in a feeble and low voice
said..."
And so forth.
Poor Don Quixote!
If Don Quixote had been killed,
this would have been a possible
ending but even in defeat,
by his being defeated,
this could have ended the novel
too.
Why doesn't it?
Well, it doesn't because he has
not yet given up his persona as
knight-errant.
Hence the process of his coming
to himself is not yet finished,
and, as I told you,
that is, his most important
task,
the task that is comparable to
the heroic one that Aeneas
accomplishes in Virgil.
The profound suggestion of Don
Quixote's defeat at the hands of
the Knight of the White Moon is
that,
given that this knight is like
the Knight of the Mirrors,
a reflection of Don Quixote
himself,
it may be that Don Quixote is
being defeated by a projection
of his own inner world.
If in Part I,
Don Quixote's body is
imprisoned in the cage,
here it is as if his spirit
were the one being defeated.
But it is again,
as if Don Quixote were
conquered by his own reflection,
by a projection of something
within his own self.
This is what is profound about
this scene.
It is easy to establish,
of course,
that the Knight of the White
Moon not only is an image of Don
Quixote--
remember, that
"luna"
meant the reflecting part of
the mirror,
"la luna del
espejo,"
but also that
"lunatic"
refers to Don Quixote's
madness.
The moon, of course,
is a celestial body of
reflected light,
so that Sansón is
reflecting Don Quixote's light
in a way,
or the projection of Don
Quixote's spirit.
I am intrigued by the name of
this knight which seems to be
redundant.
I mean, the moon is always
white, "white moon."
The doubly white moon seems to
cancel itself out in its
repeated whiteness,
like the--this brings to mind
the white pearl,
upon the white forehead,
at the end of Dante's
"Paradiso,"
white pearl on Beatrice's
forehead loses--
cannot be seen because it's
white upon white.
Don Quixote is fighting,
as it were,
against his own nothingness,
that light being,
that I mentioned before,
when alluding to Hamlet and to
Kundera,
this nothingness,
which is this white upon white,
that disappears on to itself
because white can also mean
absence,
and in that sense,
the Knight of the White Moon
can also be an image of death.
Is there any significance,
the significance to the fact
that Don Quixote is defeated by
the sea on the shore in an open
space that is nevertheless a
frontier,
a border between land and water?
Remember what I said at the
very beginning about the sea
evoking for me,
at least, an image of death.
It is an image of the infinite,
and of death.
There seems to be a
correspondence to me,
anyway, between the white of
the knight and the sea.
So this is, this dramatic
defeat of Don Quixote,
where he has to accept the
conditions set out before a
fight,
and so they begin to trudge
back to the village,
and we have this marvelous
pastoral interlude.
Don Quixote imagines a life as
a shepherd, drawn from the
pastoral romances.
Cervantes, in a way,
is adding to this,
what I've called smorgasbord of
narrative modes,
the pastoral,
but only as a project by Don
Quixote.
This would be a novel,
another novel,
parallel to the Quixote,
in which the pastoral romances
would play the role of the
chivalric ones.
Remember, that we have had a
mini Byzantine romance and a
mini morisca novel,
and if you remember,
on pages 904,905,
he says, Don Quixote:
"This is the meadow where
we lighted on the gay
shepherdesses and gallant
shepherds who intended to revive
in it,
and imitate,
the pastoral Arcadia;
a thought as new as ingenious;
in imitation of which,
if you approve it,
I could wish,
O Sancho, we might turn
shepherds, at least for the time
I must have live retired.
[Meaning, according to what he
has agreed.]
I will buy sheep,
and all other materials
necessary for the pastoral
employment;
and I, calling myself the
shepherd Quixotiz,
and you the shepherd Panzino,
we will range the mountains,
the woods and meadows,
singing here,
and complaining there,
drinking the liquid crystal of
the fountains,
of the limpid brooks,
or of the mighty rivers.
The oaks..."
And so forth.
This is a description of this
Arcadia, of the pastoral.
It is a hilarious meta- novel
that he imagines here,
in which the would-be
shepherds, Don Quixote and
Sancho,
the priest and barber,
and Sansón,
would take pastoral names,
as we have seen derived from
their own,
and give names to their ladies.
Remember, Sancho says he's
going to call his wife Teresona,
with the augmentative,
because apparently she is fat,
like him.
This is the world of
Garcilaso's eclogues brought to
Don Quixote's mind,
as he mentions it,
by the episode of the young
women,
who are preparing to stage one
of the eclogues,
which has been anticipated by
all of the references to the
poet in this Part II,
and there will be more.
It is also a circling back to
Cervantes' first book,
La Galatea,
remember, of which he always
said he would write a second
part.
In this new novel there would
be a world of love without
violence an ideal Neo-Platonic
universe.
The same clash appears in
the Quixote between a
fallen present and an ideal past
that cannot be revived in this
projected novel,
not to mention that all the
potential characters are too old
to be pastoral lovers,
and one is a priest,
who can be no lover at all.
So it is kind of a grotesque
pastoral romance in the making,
as the Quixote is,
in some ways,
also a grotesque chivalric
romance.
This is followed by the episode
where they're run over a herd of
pigs,
that critics have found that
Cervantes tinkered around of
where to place this episode,
but the important thing is that
there seems to be no end to the
humiliations that Don Quixote is
enduring towards the end of the
book,
because, remember,
that there is nothing worse
than a pig or a swineherd,
which is the word I was looking
for the other day and could not
find when alluding to the
episode where Sancho has to pass
judgment on the man who
allegedly raped a woman,
and so forth,
the man was a swineherd.
And so, our heroes are returned
forcibly to the duke and
duchess's house.
These are not satisfied with
all of the pranks that they have
made Don Quixote and Sancho
endure and prepare yet,
another, elaborate one for
them, when they hear of the
knight's defeat and return to
their village.
Cervantes inserts here a
statement by Cide Hamete to
underline the questionable state
of mind of these frivolous
aristocrats.
He says, I quote page
nine-one-nine:
"And Cide Hamete says
besides that to his thinking the
mockers were as mad as the
mocked and that the duke and
duchess were within two fingers
breath of appearing to be mad
themselves,
since they took so much pains
to make a jest of the two
fools."
So this is world where there
has been a contamination of
madness from character to
character.
The skit with the dead
Altisidora is full of literary
resonances.
The staging is elaborate with
bleachers for the audience,
an elevated place for the duke
and duchess, and blazing lights
to turn the night into day.
Such is the artifice that night
is turned into day with all of
these lights.
Sancho is costumed in a shroud
of flames and a bonnet with
devils on it,
which seem Dantesque allusions,
and the lines recited,
at least, one of the octaves
recited during the skit are
directly taken from Garcilaso's
poetry.
The farce is a representation
of the death of the beloved in
the courtly love tradition and
in Renaissance poetry.
The famous deaths are of those
Beatrice (Dante),
Laura, (Petrarch) and Isabel
Freyre (Garcilaso);
these are three ladies.
There deaths marked the poetry
of these major poets dividing
their works into the before and
then after: before the death of
Laura,
after the death of Laura,
before the death of Isabel
Freyre,
after the death, and so forth.
So this is a very significant
moment in the history of western
poetry that is being staged
here;
this is a representation of
Eros and Thanatos,
of love and death,
but in a Baroque farce
involving the protagonists,
and with a whole household,
it seems,
in attendance.
This is a prank as elaborate as
the pageant in the forest.
It is a repetition of it,
as Sancho's fall in the pit was
a repetition of the cave of
Montesinos episode.
Sancho's body,
is again, the object,
or better, the vehicle for
expiation, and the
dueñas are his
executioners;
that is, they are going to slap
him around and pinch him,
and stick pins in his butt,
and so forth,
and this is what will allow
Altisidora to be revived.
Why? Why again?
It seems that Sancho has been
cast in the role of the fool who
must suffer all of the physical
shenanigans,
meaning the fool drawn from the
carnival tradition.
This is a reading of his figure
that is parallel to the one
Avellaneda made,
by turning him to a farcical
glutton and drunk;
meaning the reading that these
duke and duchess and their
minions have done of Sancho,
because, remember,
they had read Part I,
is parallel to the one that
Avellaneda made.
This is why he is made to
endure these humiliations.
Don Quixote--the flames in his
dress and the lighting of the
courtyard seem to be an allusion
to Dido,
who burned herself to death
when abandoned by Aeneas.
Don Quixote's return and
impending departure are like
Aeneas', and Altisidora,
again, is playing the role of
Dido.
Her anger, and her insults,
which are very colorful and
actually accurately,
describe Don Quixote,
who's very ugly,
and he looks like a camel,
she says, and all of these
things.
But all of these truths play
into the fiction because it
sounds like she's saying them in
spite, because he's leaving her;
so even these truths are
absorbed into the fiction.
The whole episode is thick with
literary references and it's
staging--and it is a staging of
great literature and reducing it
to play.
Now, remember,
those who are doing this,
are the duchess and the duke,
who are these prankster
aristocrats.
Now, the most remarkable
passage in the whole sequence of
episodes involving Altisidora is
her infernal vision.
It's one of my favorite
passages in the whole book.
Sancho, as you remember,
is curious to learn what
Altisidora saw when she was
dead, what the afterworld was
like, he wants to know,
particularly hell;
he wants to know what hell is
like.
Notice, that Altisidora's
infernal voyage is like Don
Quixote's descent into the cave
of Montesinos and Sancho's fall
into the pit.
Altisidora's reply,
which she must have made up on
the spot,
like Dorotea the story of
Princess Micomicona in Part I,
is a truly brilliant boast of
imaginative skill on her part,
and of course, on Cervantes's.
Page 920: "‘In
truth,' quoth Altisidora,
'I did not die quite,
since I went not to hell;
for had I once set foot in it,
I could not have got out again,
though I had never so great a
desire.
[Remember that those who went
to hell, at the entrance of
hell, in Dante's hell,
it says, lose all hope,
you cannot ever get out of
here].
The truth is,
I came to the gate,
where about a dozen devils were
playing at tennis
["pelota"
is in Spanish.
They say "tennis,"
tennis was not invented until
the eighteenth century,
so Jarvis is indulging in a
little anachronism here,
but it's close enough],
in their waistcoats and
drawers,
their shirt-collars ornamented
with Flanders lace,
and ruffles of the same,
with four inches of the wrists
bare,
to make their hands seem the
longer,
in which they held rackets of
fire.
But what I wondered most at
was, that, instead of
tennis-balls,
they made use of books,
seemingly stuffed with wind and
flocks;
a thing marvellous and new:
but this I did not so much
wonder at,
as to see, that whereas it is
natural for winning gamesters to
rejoice,
and losers to be sorry,
among the gamesters of that
place,
all grumbled,
all were upon the fret,
and all cursed one another.'
'That is not at all strange,'
answered Sancho:
'for devils,
play or not play,
win or not win,
can never become contented.'
[Sancho is knowledgeable about
what happens in hell,
of course, he knows the oral
tradition about what is in hell,
and how...]
'It is true,' quoth Altisidora:
'but there is another thing I
wondered at,
I mean, I wondered at it,
then [She has corrected
herself,
because she's speaking in the
present,
and she says no,
no, and she's making it up,
again, remember that Dorotea
makes a mistake,
also, and has to be corrected
when she's making it up]
which was,
that, at the first toss the
ball was demolished,
and could not serve a second
time;
and so they whipped them away,
and new and old,
that it was marvelous to
behold: and to one of them,
flaming new,
and neatly bound,
they gave such a smart stroke,
that they made it its guts fly
out,
and scattered its leaves all
about,
and one devil said to another:
"See what that book
is";
and the other deviled answered:
"It is the Second Part
of the History of Don Quixote de
la Mancha,
not composed by Cid Hamet,
its first author,
but by an Aragonese,
who calls himself a native of
Tordesillas."
[You have that on your cover of
Avellaneda's.]
"Away with it,"
quoth the other devil,
"and down with it to the
bottom of the infernal abyss,
that my eyes may never see it
more."
"Is it so bad?"
answered the other.
"So bad,"
replied the first,
"that, had I myself
undertaken to make it worse,
it had been past my skill."
They went on with their play,
tossing other books and up and
down...'"
And so forth.
There is a lot of Dante in this
episode,
but the story of devil's
playing a form of tennis,
"pelota,"
with the souls or the heads of
the dead,
is a traditional story,
gruesome.
But Cervantes has embroidered
upon it, by making them use
books, instead of heads,
or souls, for balls.
The attack on Avellaneda is
very funny, but the commentary
on books goes beyond the
apocryphal Quixote.
This episode reflects a change
in the appraisal of books by the
beginning of the seventeenth
century in the west.
Their value has diminished.
It seems to follow an
elementary economic law:
with the advent of the printing
press the number of books
increased dramatically,
and then, the value of each
decreased--
I mean, this is basic
economics--But it is more
complicated than that.
Philosophy move toward
knowledge as a result of
experience, not as something
acquired from authoritative
sources whose works where in
books.
In Spain neo-scholasticism,
about which you have read in
Elliott,
which was a revival of the
medieval philosophy of the
church fathers and which relied
on syllogism and the opinion of
authoritative sources had become
the ideology of the state.
Neo-scholasticism,
doctrine, whatever you want to
call it, and religious,
it was the ideology of the
Spanish crown.
Logic argumentation and
authorities supplied the
foundations of knowledge.
We have seen something of that,
and I mention it in the satire
of doctors,
in the person of doctor Pedro
Recio Tirteafuera who says to
Sancho,
'you cannot eat this,
you cannot eat that,' the
knowledge of medicine at the
time was based simply on books
not on experience.
So the situation in the rest of
Europe was not as extreme,
by philosophical thought
nonetheless rejected bookish
learning in favor of experience
and individual thought.
The greatest exponent of this
was Descartes,
whom I have mentioned several
times in the course of the
semester,
and a precursor,
if you wish,
although in a milder or lighter
kind of philosophical
speculation was Montaigne.
Anthony Grafton,
professor at Princeton,
opens the introduction of his
magnificent book,
New Worlds,
Ancient Texts: the Power
of Tradition and the Shock of
Discovery with these words,
quote: "Between 1550 and
1650 western thinkers ceased to
believe that they could find all
important truths in ancient
books." Unquote.
Grafton goes on to quote Jesuit
José de Acosta,
who published a very important
book, a very comprehensive book
about the history of the New
World,
called Historia natural y
moral,
"moral"
means culture,
"natural"
is physical,
the nature and
"moral"
means culture,
de las Indias.
This book is from the 1590s,
1592, or something like that,
I can't remember.
But he says,
he quotes Acosta,
who says the following,
quote:
"Having read what poets
and philosophers write of the
torrid zone I persuaded myself
that when I came to the equator
[he's on a ship on his way to
the New World]
I would not be able to endure
the heat but it turned out
otherwise,
for when I passed the equator I
felt so cold that I was forced
to go into the sun to warm
myself.
What could I do,
but laugh at Aristotle's
meteorology?"
Says Acosta.
This is mocked,
by the way, in chapter XIX of
Part II,
in the episode of the enchanted
boat,
meaning that the actual
experience of travel demolishes
traditional knowledge,
the traditional knowledge being
whether Sancho's lice would die
when they cross a certain line,
and so forth,
remember all of that is mocked,
but this is what is behind it.
Ironically, then,
the proliferation of books,
being--at the time,
"when the authority of the
book was most severely tested
and ultimately devalued."
That is, the proliferation of
books takes place at the time
"when the authority of the
book was most severely tested
and ultimately devalued."
The ability to read many books
did not bring one closer to
wisdom but to an inordinate,
perhaps infinite enlargement of
the library and perhaps to Don
Quixote's madness.
I believe that this is what is
implicit in this marvelous
passage of Altisidora's infernal
visitation.
As customary,
Cervantes deals with very
complicated issues,
in such an unaffected
spontaneous and amusing way that
it seems almost like a miracle,
but this is what is behind this
episode about books being
whacked with burning flaming
rackets.
We will be dealing chiefly with
the end of the Quixote in
the last two lectures.